could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
i lost my dad i lost my marriage i saw
my company then you sort of ask yourself
what are you doing with your life
my name is marcus buckingham he's a
best-selling author a rock star in
corporate america i couldn't say my own
name until i was 12. the more you try to
fix a stammer the worse it gets from a
very early age we start telling people
that strength is what you're good at but
yeah i'm good at some things i hate
what's that that's a weakness i had got
myself into a position where i was
solely responsible for one huge client
disney i look like i sort of feel
confident but i had years of panic
attacks it was super psychologically
damaging
to be trying to be somebody that you're
not
the first relationship you better have
is a really good one with yourself
the best people in any job they find
love in the activities themselves love
is for work and work is for love and if
we do that it's not just
individualistically satisfying it's what
companies want from us
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
dyrova ceo usa edition i hope nobody's
listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
marcus it's uh it's a pleasure to have
you here in our studio here in la
another brit sir sir we've had quite a
few brits in but um you're one that's
particularly inspired me with your work
when i was doing the research on you and
reading through your book and your prior
book um i
i was overwhelmed with the amount of
questions i wanted to ask you because of
the the depth of knowledge but also how
much the topics you talk about resonate
with me the place i wanted to start with
you though that i found particularly
surprising having met you having spoken
to you having seen how people have um
become very enamored with you as a
public speaker is
you started your life with a stammer yes
a really bad stammer yes how does
someone get from and i want to talk
about that but for context you went from
having a stammer which was pretty
crippling in terms of social aspects to
mark french who's the us us's top
lecturer
the leader of the top lecture agency
called you one of the best public
speakers he's ever seen how does one go
from having a stammer and being you know
really hindered by it to that position
and tell me about the stannah
yeah so when i first started to speak
and this happens for quite a lot more
boys than girls actually as a hams my
synapse synapses um
didn't fire right
and so you have almost immediate
disfluency so my earliest memories steve
are not being able to say my name
one of my very earliest fears was not
ever being able to be married because i
couldn't say will you marry me so you
start off and you start trying to
communicate at three and four
and then you realize that something's
really wrong but you're so young you
don't really understand what's wrong and
then you get older and older you realize
you can't
you can't put words together
um so for the first 12 years of my life
not being able to speak was what i
thought about every single moment of
every day and everyone's got their own
traumas and their own difficulties and
i had lots of blessings in my life but
um i couldn't speak and i had a lot to
say so
i would keep trying and then it wouldn't
work and i didn't know why and a stem is
a really it's a perfect metaphor for
everything that parents
try to do with their kids you the more
you try to fix a stammer the worse it
gets
so i went to the speech pathologist and
they did the whole
peter piper picture peck of pickle
peckers thing and you
trying to sort of get them
the muscles to kick in and it just got
worse and worse and most of us and then
i was one of five boys that was asked to
read aloud in chapel i had kept
volunteering to be in christmas plays
and stuff and i was never picked because
everyone rightly was like uh he can't
talk so i'd never really spoken in front
of anyone at all
when i was talking to you like if i was
seven years old and talking to you like
this i couldn't say anything like i
wouldn't
i would try and then you would be like
this is
mortify so i'd never been asked to read
aloud anywhere anyway that day
i can start
my palms are sweating even just thinking
about it because you realize
my life's over
every single child in the school is
going to see me now stand up i can't
fake the words because they've got the
bible study books because it was in
chapel so they can see what i'm supposed
to read so i can't i used to substitute
words that i could say for words i
couldn't it's an old stammers trick
but they're like you can see what i'm
going to read and
girls and boys at that age as you know
can be pretty cruel um so i'm like i'm
done i'm just baked you know stick a
fork in me
but anyway i walk up and i turn around
and i look at all the faces and i it was
it was like a
a stimulus
and then my response my brain felt
different that's all i can say about it
just felt different felt warmer it felt
fluid
and
i just read the whole piece with not a
single stemmer really just the whole
thing and what
occurred to me was
i love
the eyes on me that sounds really weird
the more people i'm talking to
i'm better
brain comes faster words
come out better stories that i don't
know why i didn't work at it i didn't
struggle with that
it was just that worked on me
in the same way that some people over
summer when they sing they don't have a
stomach so i took that away i was
blown away i didn't understand it but um
then i just went you know what that
should be an unlock for me
we often go to our
deep traumas to try to understand how to
fix ourselves and if you have social
anxiety or what caused it where did it
start and we sort of
we we pathologize ourselves with the
best of intentions but i went the other
way and i was like i know so much about
this dance demo i've been to more
speech pathology sessions and read more
books and i know so much about i just
can't fix it instead i'm going to
i'm gonna decide that when i talk to one
person i'll just pretend i'm talking to
400. i'll just literally pretend i'm
talking to 400.
and the stammer went away in a week
i was faking public speaking when i was
just speaking and i was doing it as a
coping mechanism so that i didn't
stammer
and it worked it's fascinating it's
weird makes no sense
right it's like
we're mysterious and that's what i read
about in the book is that i don't think
we've really grabbed hold of that this
huge variability in variety that lives
in human beings
we have talked about it in terms of race
or gender or age or nationality or
religion but we haven't really talked
about it in terms of why are you
different from your brother by the time
you get to be about 18 19 you have a
hundred trillion synaptic connections in
your brain that lead you to love some
things and load others
things that shouldn't go together go
together things that you lean into
that you shouldn't lean into but you do
like for me i shouldn't have loved
public speaking but for some daft reason
i did why no idea but we
we have this unbelievably intricate
network of synaptic connections that
makes us completely different from the
person
we grew up in the same house with
and what no one's ever taught us is a
um how do you understand that uniqueness
like what are the signs life is giving
you and b
how do you use it like can you rewire
your brain to become someone else what
happens if you put your ten thousand
dollars in can you rewire your brain and
become a different human being can you
rewire that network in your brain
well if you have a growth mindset
supposedly you you should and yet
actually we know that's not what happens
at all you grow more synaptic
connections in the part of your brain
you have the most pre-existing synaptic
connections everyone
because you've got the alpha instagram
proteins and the blood vessels and the
infrastructure so actually growth for
all of us is becoming actually a more
defined
version of who you are you don't rewire
your brain becomes someone else the
question in life isn't really growth or
no growth it's where will you grow the
most
so
i don't think we've ever really graph
grappled with the 11 year old who's
basically asking herself who am i
is there a me in there
and we could have 10 years of school
yes where we learned geometry we could
have 10 years going here's how to use
the raw material of a week of school to
start helping you know a little bit more
about that weird
massive and massively filigreed network
in your brain
and we could help you learn to have a
language around that and how to describe
it without bragging or
how to be interested in other people's
network
we could do all of that and of course as
you know as an entrepreneur you want to
hire people like that because then they
have mastery of themselves
so when they join a team they can start
going well you can lean into me for this
and you know here's a bit where i
struggle actually i need some help and
here's where things come really fast and
here's where i'm like a deer in the
headlights
but i know certainly in the company that
i built it's like you don't hire people
like that you tend to hire people that
are completely lovely
and smart but really quite inarticulate
at describing
where
they find love and what they do where
they're at their best and where they
struggle we don't we just haven't
grappled with the beautiful wonderful
extensive variation
of us as individuals
and when you were that age when you
weren't say 11 or 13 or 14 what was if
i'd asked you what you wanted to do when
you're older what would the answer have
been
i didn't if i go all the way back to 9
or ten i wouldn't have known what i
wanted to be
i did know that i started to pay
attention to things that other people
didn't pay attention to and that was
interesting then at 16 i bumped into
this
titan of
positive psychology his name was dr don
clifton
who um was the chairman of gallup but
also his chief scientist
and so at 16 he said
you're going to go study psychology and
i had chosen psychology and he was like
come to lincoln nebraska and i'll say
i'll teach you about positive psychology
and studying what's right with people
and i was like
all right i'll do that
didn't know where it would lead but knew
that research in psychology
real world observed human behavior i
just was always interested in that for
people that don't know what is gallup
oh well gallup's the first company i
joined after school after university
gallup was founded by george gallup who
was the inventor of polling you like
polling i hate it he figured out
something which was
if you talk to 10 000
very carefully selected people your
predictions of what they're going to do
or vote for anything is more accurate
than taking
100 000 people because you're 100 000
people might be skewed but if you have
what's called a representative sample in
your 10 000 then you've actually can
extrapolate from your 10 000
to 100 million
um now there's subtleties around that
but but that's where it started after
george died
don clifton bought the company
and don's focus was psychometrics so how
do you measure things about a human that
are really really important but you
can't count how can you measure
engagement how can you measure strengths
how can you measure
resilience
um
talent how do you measure that
could i figure out a set of questions
that would help me discover
something about you in terms of your
strengths your talents your advantages
your attributes that you don't even know
yourself like i just loved that idea
and so half of gallup was polling and
half of gallup was
psychometrics
and so i was there for the first 17
years of my career and we built this
this tool that 25 million people have
taken called strength finder um strength
finder is all about exactly what it says
um let's try and measure you on 34
strengths and then we'll give you your
top five um so that was the side that i
spent my
first 17 years of my career with is
trying to measure the uniqueness of
human beings
from a top line perspective when you
were in that role because i mean 17
years trying to remember to find the
uniqueness in human beings and
inventing this thing called strength
finder
what is what did you learn about what a
strength is because when i think about
strength i think it is
um
i guess just something that i'm good at
yeah so
when you dive into what a strength is
what you find is it's shot through with
emotion it's what you love to do what do
you lean into what do you find yourself
unable to stop doing there's a there's
an obsessive
um and joyous quality to a strength so
when you push and push and push on a
strength people think that a strength is
what you're good at this is what you're
bad at
but actually if you push on that even
just a little stevie you bump into
people going but i'm really good at that
and i hate it what's that
what's it where you're really good at it
even in school when you've got an a and
you're like i'm thank goodness that
classes over because i don't want to
take it again but your parents go well
you got an a in fact you've got an in
biology so you might want to do medicine
you should be a doctor but deep down
yourself going but i don't i don't like
sick people i actually don't like
sickness at all and yet no matter as a
doctor you keep curing them there's
another one the next day they keep
coming to my darn office you know i'm
never done
and and so we from a very early age we
start telling people that strength is
what you're good at but yet our own
human experiences i'm good at some
things i hate
what's that well you push on that that's
a weakness and so we should change our
definition a weakness
is any activity that weakens you any
activity where before you do it you
don't want to do it while you're doing
it time drags on when you're done with
it you feel drained
that's a weakness i don't care how good
you are at it if that's how you feel
after it and then somebody were to say
to you build your career around that
that's sadistic
but that's
that's
that's the proper definition of a
weakness is if it weakens you definition
of a strength is any activity that
strengthens you before you do it you
lean into it you sort of just can't stop
yourself from volunteering while you're
doing it time whips by and you're like
you look up you thought it was an hour
right it's and it's now it's it's
you've been doing it for seven hours and
you're like oh my god and then when
you're done with it you're like
i i know i feel
completed or i feel like me or i feel
authentic right i don't feel drained i
might not want to do it right away again
but i'm like
you're from the latin right you're
invigorated you're strengthened
which of course means if a strength is
what strengthens you and a weakness is
what weakens you what's super cool about
that is that you're the best judge of
both no one knows better than you what
we consider and what strengthens you
from the nine years old we could be
saying to people hey what strengthens
you about even video games okay which
video game what what about it is it
multiplayer game as a first person
shooter we could start to get people to
be
cultivating their own kind you know
genius about
what what are your strengths
somebody else is the judge of your
performance no question so if you say i
really really love um
remembering people's names
no one can come in and say no no you
don't they can't say well you should
probably use that to um give better
customer service and here's how you
might want to do that but no one can
come in and say you don't love that
because if you say no no i no i do
then you're the best judge of that now
we might want to help you learn the
detail of that well what do you mean by
helping people what do you mean by
learning their names or what bit about
it so we could help you get more
detailed around it but a strength
is what strengthens you and you are the
only genius when it comes to your
strengths 17 years with gallup that's
sort of the biggest takeaway
and strength finder or other tools like
that can help you sort of get in the
vicinity
of what are your strengths
but really a strength there's an
activity that strengthens you
and
and life frankly is waking up every day
kind of putting on a show for you going
what about this what about this what
about this what about this
um
and yeah you're on the receiving end
going hmm
how about that what is it about that
17 years at gallup you know
the other thing i was thinking about
before you arrived was you must know how
to ask a good question
because that's sort of central to
gallup's work is knowing how to ask the
right type of question and there's so
many questions that are trying to get to
the same answer but there's various
routes you can take and the divergence
between i guess the in terms of outcome
of a good question and a bad question
must be quite significant like if i'm
trying to find out what motivates you
there's a number of ways that i could
ask that and i think a lot of the ways
that i would ask that simple question
would actually lead me to the wrong
place because they're like laced with
biases and presumptions and maybe
they're not open maybe they're too
binary so how does one go about because
asking good questions is so important in
life generally whether you're trying to
help a friend you're trying to hire
someone you're trying to understand
anything it's all about inquiry um how
does one ask better questions is there
did you learn anything about that i got
it
well you're right that's that's what the
product is
and you would test it out you would do
what's called a concurrent validity
study where you take 100 really good
managers and 100 average ones and you
try out 250 questions
250 questions and you see which
questions elicit patterns of answers
that the best people in a role do versus
ones that are less successful
and many of the questions that you
thought were great questions you have to
throw out because they don't work as in
the most successful people don't answer
them in any way that's similar to each
other and different than these people so
that's really what the business was
trying out lots of different questions
to figure out
what are the best questions you can ask
in this case for a particular role or
job but in general
if you wanna if you wanna ask really
good questions the first thing to know
is you should be asking open-ended
questions
so you're asking
um what did you love most about your
previous work
um
open not yes knows like just open-ended
what what did you love most about that
so the that's the it sounds like an
obvious thing but it's amazing how
close-ended our questions are as opposed
to like what would be an example of a
close did you love managing people are
you an overachiever or an underachiever
um you know or um do you like overcoming
people's resistance to your ideas
yes so you can
if you're not careful you close the
answer down
best questions are always like uh
tell me about a time when you uh
when you built something you didn't
expect to build
it's just open hard to measure though
right if it's open that's why i think
people avoid open questions right
because then because then you get such a
dive like variety of answers how do you
like
put them in categories
well when it comes to psychometrics you
have a listen for and you code it
plus when you hear the listen for and
zero for everything else like boiling
and not boiling so when you're actually
building an instrument it's maybe too
inside baseball as it were but
inside cricket
but that's how you do it when you're
building an instrument so for example
you take a question like um how do you
know if you're doing a good job of
listening
let's say that
you're trying to figure out empathy and
you decide that one of the ways to
measure empathy would be a question like
how do you know if you're doing a good
job of listening so you take your study
group of highly empathetic
people
your contrast group of less and you
experiment with a whole bunch of
questions one of them is that one well
it turns out by the way that one does
have a listen for
a really good listen for what to listen
for
um a pattern of responses that the most
empathetic people all seem to share even
though they don't know one another okay
and the listen for if you imagine all
the possible answers to that question
how do you know if you're doing a good
job of listening you could imagine
somebody's saying well if i can repeat
back to the person what they said or if
i just nod or like all sorts of uh if i
mirror their embody language
turns out the most empathetic people all
say the same thing
um
they don't say it in exactly the same
way but they say exactly the same thing
they all say i know
i'm doing a good job of listening when
the other person keeps talking
well that's interesting because that
means the empathetic person
instinctively knows that the job of a
listener is not to understand what the
person's saying
interestingly the job of a listener is
to be
however they do it in such a way that
you keep talking
the job the outcome of listening is the
other person sharing
what you realize in most interviews
frankly first of all that the interview
split of time is 60 40 the wrong way the
interviewer talks for 60 of the time in
the interview he talks for 40.
so we've got a big imbalance and by the
way the interviewer rates the person
more highly in a job interview when the
interviewer talks most there's a very
strong voice really yeah totally
when i've talked to you
i rate maybe you didn't when you're
building your company but
across the board when you study this
there's a positive correlation between
amount of time the interviewer talks and
the rating of the interviewee wow um but
anyway the in terms of building the
instrument once you've got oh wow
all the most empathetic people say the
same thing to that question how do you
know if you're doing a good job of
listening when the other person keeps
talking well then that becomes a listen
for and then whenever you're trying to
measure empathy you throw that question
out you shut up
you let the person talk and then if you
hear unprompted off the top of their
head if they just say unprompted by you
no cues from you no biases from you no
nudging because i like the look of you
when you walked in you just shut up even
when the person says what do you mean by
that you and by the way this is one of
the tricks of interviewing you have to
learn your parry phrases a parry phrase
is like
when somebody because everyone wants to
try to narrow you down i'm sure in
dragon's den you've seen this like
people try to narrow you down towards
getting to the place where you say yes
and so when somebody says you know how
do you know if you're doing a good job
of listening the interviewee tends to
say well what do you mean by that you
mean at home or at work do you mean if i
know them really well if i don't and the
tendency because that's just what humans
do is to go oh uh
work
or when someone you don't know what and
you narrow it down so they can get the
right answer so you have to learn a
parry phrase like
well i know what i mean by that but i'm
interested in what you mean by that just
to knock it back just to knock it back
and then
if you aren't if you ask a question like
that and the person spontaneously goes
if the other person keeps talking and
then you actually code that you can
score it going back to your question
about how do you score it you can score
that you didn't tell them what to say
you asked an open-ended question and you
knew what you were listening for and so
you can code it in this case a plus and
everything else isn't a bad answer it's
just a non-predictive answer of that
particular trait
um
there's a whole bunch i mean
if you wanted to select really good
sales people
um
here's a great question
how do you feel when someone doubts what
you have to say
how do you feel open-ended how do you
feel when someone doubts what you have
to say imagine all the possible answers
to that question
and what you find is highly successful
people get 100 of them less successful
salespeople get 100 of them
these people
in answer to that question how do you
feel
when someone doubts what you have to say
they all say
it pisses me off
the successful ones yes
look
don't buy from me that's all right
disagree with me that's all right don't
doubt me
what we called we did call it this a
negative emotional reaction
because when you're a salesperson you're
like listen
i i respect the fact that you can choose
what product or service you might want
to go with don't doubt me it's like when
people say with salespeople well you
shouldn't take rejection personally the
best salespeople are like are you
kidding
that's what i'm selling
i'm me
so in this case when you put the word
doubt in there
it's like
it's like a bang and you're like oh uh
uh
don't doubt me so the listen for there
is like very specific by the way when
you ask great teachers that question
and average teaches that question
they say completely the opposite
they say the best teachers go i love
that
because to them are not all teachers
because there's a whole bunch of
teachers who don't say that but you look
at great teachers they go no the doubt
is a student
i want the student to be doubting that's
learning
and so you've got asked that for the
great nurses average nurses the question
doesn't work anymore
because who doubts a nurse yeah you know
so it's
with all these things i'm sure you found
with your business you can ask one
question and then
you're really just trying to pin your
ears back
shut the heck up
and let the person ramble because it's
so
revealing
even a question like what did you enjoy
most about your previous work yeah i
mean what a great question that is and
again people will say well what do you
mean with previous work do you mean this
job but you'll go hey
what did you enjoy most about your
previous work just talk to me about it
it's
well i think it's fascinating and it's
predictive like you can start to predict
what people are going to do
if you can hear what they have
repeatedly done people say you know past
behavior is the best predictor of future
behavior no it isn't repeated past
behavior is the best predictor of
repeated future behavior so if you want
to know repeated past behavior you ask
an open-ended question and then you shut
up and top of mind is what the person
repeatedly does or thinks or feels and
it's so revealing
we just mostly in conversation we just
talk at each other well i did this well
i did oh you didn't fall asleep wasn't
that i didn't policy loves neither you
missed your plane i've missed my place
yeah you know it said like waiting to
talk exactly in your first book um you
talked a lot about employee satisfaction
so your first book is called first break
all the rules and
you really highlight the importance of
employee satisfaction and i think you
know a lot of people might think oh yeah
keeping employees happy is you know
you know i'll we'll do our best but
um it really is
from your read from your um your work
it's clear that it's central to the
success of a company i guess my first
question is then
what is the single biggest predictor or
the unexpected predictor of employee
satisfaction in the workplace because i
would think it was like you know one
might think it would be
how much you pay them or how many
holiday days they get what did you find
out
well the two biggest things from all of
this research and it sort of goes full
circle from first break all the rules
which was the first book
i wrote which is based upon gallup
research in you know way back when but
it comes all the way full circle steve
to this book which
is all about love
um
when you push and push and push on your
question what you bump into is an item a
survey item
that just keeps showing up
in people
that are more likely to stay with you
more likely to be productive more likely
to have fewer lost work days less likely
to sue frankly if they have an accident
on the job like all sorts of really good
predictive real world outcomes are more
likely to happen when someone says
firstly
um i have a chance to use my strengths
every day
or i love what i do and i'm good at
um
there's something about person work fit
person work fit this job has some big
bits of it that fit me
now who me is is variable of course but
is this job in any way an alien job to
me or is that actually part of me when
you have that in any job
we were talking before about the first
job i ever studied was housekeepers
where we think oh you know how to keep a
stupid job i mean i bet they all just
want to get out of it as quickly as they
can but you study the world's best
housekeepers and you're like oh my word
there are some people that love certain
aspects of that role any role done at
excellence has got a lot of love in it
and every role done averagely is
loveless if you have loveless work
you're a worse worker we now know all
sorts of biochemical reasons why that's
so but it just kept showing up in survey
after survey after survey
work you fit however you want to talk
about that is huge
which is why of course i'm sure when you
built your company you realize this
teams are everything teams are
everything because they make homes for
unique individuals and you can start
going ah you're all weird but but you do
this and you do this and you do this and
you do this and lo and behold the team's
well-rounded precisely because each
person on it isn't well-rounded and then
the team leader of course can be really
creative about well which bit of it do
you love and can we get you to do a bit
more of that and then you can lean into
this person who weirdly loves balancing
the books but you hate it well that's
interesting they love excel you love
powerpoint okay well that's it that's a
team and and so that's
that's all about person work
uh fit
so that's a huge one um and then of
course the second one in terms of
um
in terms of all the discoveries around
engagement is um
it's your manager stupid
it's like
if you think if you don't trust your
manager if your manager doesn't know you
if your manager doesn't pay attention to
you
then your whole company becomes the
manager
and you can actually walk around your
neighborhood going you know what it's a
pretty good company
but i freaking hate her
and if you freaking hate her you leave
i left the company's great now if you
flip that around so you can go the
company's terrible like the pay is bad
and the and the
you know the benefits package isn't
really what it's cracked up but my
manager steve he's i mean i would follow
him anywhere
which by the way sometimes happens when
steve moves companies so those two
things of everything i'm i'm not saying
that pay is nothing or benefits and
nothing people like those things but if
you want to see where people give that
discretionary effort if you want to see
where certain teams saw and you go why
why is that team crushing it and this
team's struggling which by the way you
go inside companies you start measuring
anything uh lost work days productivity
sales profitability and what you find
and no one talks about this but you find
variation you go inside of
you go inside of home depot
or you go inside of marx and spencer's
or you go inside of goldman sachs so you
go inside of tesla you go inside of
disney oh well disney's got this culture
tesla's got that culture all of that is
rubbish you go inside a company let's
just take tesla and you start measuring
what's it like to work here what you get
is range
what's it like to work at tesla depends
massively on which bloody team you're on
and if you are working on a team down
here that's disengaged your manager
doesn't care about you're not trusted
that's tesla and when you leave you're
leaving that
now this team over here is a super
engaged ship that same business card
tesla tesla but you i don't know you
read the i don't know what you read but
you read the business press it sure
looks as though companies have one
culture rubbish they have as many
cultures as they do teams they have one
stock price
but that's a totally different ball game
so in terms of what drives engagement on
this team does someone really think
about how i can fit the work that i'm
doing a lot of and then do i really
trust that my team leader is out to make
me bigger
better he's interested in that when
those two things i'm not saying there
are other things recognition's important
mission you're going to talk to simon
while you're here the why is important
but the why doesn't compensate for the
what if what you're doing on that team
doesn't fit you
it's like nurses
you know why we have such burned out
nurses in the nhs and over here too
their why couldn't be stronger of course
their why is so
vivid and yet they're burning out they
have higher levels of ptsd than veterans
that return from war zones
it's like we're crushing our nurses why
well one many reasons but one reason is
the span of control one nurse supervisor
to 60 nurses
which is the average over here i don't
know exactly what the average is in the
nhs but it's really big there's no teams
in hospitals hospitals aren't built
around teams they're built around
vertical areas of expertise so if you're
a nurse
60 of you one nurse supervisor that poor
nurse supervisor can't do those two
things i just mentioned he or she can't
get to know you in terms of where your
strengths and passions lie
and then they can't put you on a team to
help you be collaborative with others so
that together you can reinforce and
support one another in those areas where
you don't have strength or love or
whatever
humans have been working in teams 50 000
years and if you go to hospitals
there are no teams because the structure
is set up to make it impossible and then
we wonder we go out and we clap
but it's all a bit
it's like hey rather than
dragging people out of the river who are
drowning
why don't we go upstream
and see why they're why we're pushing
them in in the first place
with nurses we've built a system where
they don't get those two things those
two needs met no one's interested in who
they are and what they bring and no one
has enough time to pay attention to how
they're feeling what they're into what
they're not into who could they can work
with like all of that stuff that humans
need
that particular profession
doesn't get and that's the reason why in
all of our studies i run the adp
research institute now which is a big
global institute
it's the least resilient profession of
all even pre-pandemic it was
and funnily enough the second most
uh burned out is teachers
so the two
most burned out least resilient
professions have the clearest why
the clearest sense of purpose
but the reality of the work the
day-to-day reality of the work is super
disengaging there's no teams in schools
it's like wherever you see no teams
you get no trust in team leader and no
link between you and your work you and
your role you and your role it's like
teams of this magic
technology
that we discovered 50 000 years ago when
we tried to bring down big game it's so
interesting you say that because um i've
always pondered so there's so many
things that i thought about there the
first thing was actually how right you
are having seen in my own organization
over the years where i would do my
one-on-ones with team members and
if
jason fisher
was managing the team
even though they were in the same room
they're all in the design department but
the 15 people jason fisher was managing
would have reported tremendously high
levels of job satisfaction
a team sat next to him doing pretty much
the same work would come in and i was
i felt like i was fighting to keep them
in the company because they were managed
sat next to the other team managed by a
different person and the crazy thing is
in the second team i describes
one-on-one sessions with me they would
ask to be managed by jason fisher
they would say could we
and then eventually our decision as a
company was to put jason fisher up above
the whole
design studio so he was he was in charge
of 40 people but then he could like
oversee
the team and those people were happy and
then the second thing you said just at
the end though which really made me
think was um
about freelancers
and about their levels of engagement and
motivation they are not in teams they
tend to work at home alone on computers
on work which actually is not connected
to them a different project today a
different project tomorrow and i believe
that
they
mus just it's this is an anecdotal thing
that i've seen in my friends that
freelancers i think they struggle the
most in terms of fulfillment and
happiness in their work generally
obviously there's perks
but generally
no you're absolutely right the data
would back you up a thousand percent
we've just finished we did a 25 000
person 25 country study two years ago
just came out of the field three days
ago with a 27 000 person study 27
countries the least engaged really least
resilient professions are people who are
uh alone who are working as
exactly as you said
um that doesn't mean that there aren't
some benefits to your point they do
actually like the flexibility
but
they only want places where it really
works is where the company and there's a
few companies that do this actually
because of the labor laws or whatever
you stay fleet you know in a freelance
role but actually you're brought into
the team you're treated like a member of
the team
look that
in 2017 i wrote about this too because i
just was fascinated by the fact that the
el the oldest human art we've ever found
like in 2017 this guy in the little
island of sulawesi in indonesia he's
climbing up in a limestone cave and he's
looking for a hand print because that's
the oldest art we've ever found is like
a red handprint in ochre or something
he's looking to see if he can find it
and he comes
climbs in
takes his um iphone and he's got a
15-foot mural on the wall
and the mural turns out to be 50 000
years old so it's the oldest human art
we've ever found well maybe sorry 44 000
years but they think it's actually
conservatively it's 44 000 years old
and it's a painting not a hand
not of a foot or a face even it's a
painting of
a bunch of little human figures some
carrying spears some carrying rope
and then very clearly the local um fauna
so an anoa a deer
uh a wild cat and clearly
this group of people is trying to get
together to capture or kill these
animals
and what's cool about it is that the
artist and they think most artists cave
artists was done by women so they think
it was women
has drawn each human figure
with an animal characteristic
so one of them has the face of a lion
one of them has a
tail of a crocodile one of them has a
trunk of an oven
and they're called therianthropes
who knows why but anthropology is called
half man half animal um
therianthropes
and
what it looks as though has happened is
the artist has looked across
the cave across the fire and going ooh
she's super wily like a crocodile and
he's really strong so he's brave and
this one and
she's represented a team of differently
talented people
so what's super cool about it i think
and i could just be geeking out on it
but the oldest human expression of us
with each other
is a manifestation of how different we
are from one another
in the cave
and how acutely astute that person must
have been to spotted and then went hey
what happens if we all
came together and then we could do
together what we can't do alone and then
everyone went all right i'll try that
and then it worked and then they
memorialized it on a cave and that's
called a team
and then fast forward 50 000 years we go
to schools and hospitals and we build
places with no teams or call centers or
manufacturing facilities and it's like
uh you've run a business you what you
just said by the way data backs this up
a thousand percent too you can go into a
company and you can ask a question like
i trust my team leader or do i know
what's expected of me at work and you've
got two teams in the same room and
you'll have one team where ninety
percent of people strongly agree that i
know what's expected of me
and this doing the same job right next
door where less than 40 percent do
and i remember when i was like really
young in my career i'd walk back into a
company and the ceo would go because we
did these surveys and they would go
what's our culture like and i would go
um well uh
this team everyone knows what's expected
of them and then right next door there's
a team that doesn't has no idea what
they're doing
and that you could see o what what
because we've got policies and we've got
goal setting and we a software that
enables cascaded goals to hit people
like and you go yeah i know we've bought
a new sofa for the whole lot too so they
should have the and you're like i don't
know but there's huge variation inside
that room
and
you in terms of your experience had that
ins you know
every single place you looked you found
variation but you don't it's funny you
don't really read that much about it i
don't you don't you don't it's actually
weirdly this is kind of the first time
i've really deeply pondered it i i can
see it having happened in my company but
i can see it happening office to office
so our office in manchester versus
office in london eris in london was
really not good good in terms of
satisfaction at one point our office in
manchester was amazing and just
yeah and i and you the real point that
stuck with me is that you don't have one
culture
i'm like that's kind of been a bit
unnerving for me it's made me rethink a
couple of the decisions i made but um
the other thing i i
i know you wrote about in that before we
get on to this one is you talked about
how great managers handle
underperformers
and how every team has people that
underperform that are for whatever
reason
from what you've understood
how do great managers handle people that
aren't performing
to a certain standard
so the first thing that we've got to
remember about all managers and again we
don't hear this much discussed either is
um
like why do we all hate the performance
review why do we all hate the annual
performance review
many reasons because when i go through
it and somebody says you're a four i go
well i'm not a number
um so there's that part of it but also
it's too infrequent right once a year so
you go in going i've got to tell this
person everything i'm worried about
anxious about thinking about because i'm
not going to talk to them again for a
year it's too infrequent the best
managers know
that the world moves quickly there's 52
little sprints that's a year 52 little
sprints
so the best managers are checking in
with each of their people really light
touch like 10 minutes 15 minutes but
every week
one-on-one every week one-on-one
really simple questions like would you
love last week and load what are your
priorities this week how can i help but
like that every week little because
remember the goals you set the beginning
of the year are irrelevant by the third
week of the year i mean we're in the
middle right now like also it's a global
conflict we didn't know that three weeks
ago so we also know from data by the way
people don't go back in and check their
goals so
less than four percent of people
once they set a goal at the beginning of
the year maybe there's a software
program that records it or whatever
they don't go back in and check it but
we all know it changes so dramatically
even in the next couple of weeks so the
first thing is the best managers are
frequently going how was last week how
was next week how was it it's really
this sort of that rhythm it's like 52
little sprints like that
and of course that means if you've got
an underperformer
you are hitting it
really early you don't wait until
december and go you
have had a bad year you're a two right
you're hitting it every week and because
you're hitting it every week
you've got an opportunity much earlier
to start saying two things the first
is
and this is so it sounds so obvious but
for one of the questions that separates
a good manager from a bad manager by the
way is you put this question to them
you've got someone who comes into work
consistently late what would you do so
you take a study group take a contrast
group 100 great managers 100 average
ones and you just throw that question
out you've got someone who comes into
work consistently late what would you do
when you again think of a million
different answers to that question these
folks here they all stay the good ones
yeah the stuff we call it the study
group when you're doing a concurrent
validity study you take a hundred
great ones measurably and then 100
average i won't get into how you measure
it but it's like
that's that's how you do it
and anyway these ones here their first
their top of mind response unprompted is
i would ask why
before i do anything else i would say
why are you coming in late maybe is it a
bus issue did you miss that you got
something with your kid is it a drop-off
time should i change your start time to
9 30. so you can get you can what if you
start by assuming this is a real human
you start by assuming this person's not
trying to get one over on you which is
kind of an interesting mindset it's like
the best managers start i think douglas
mcgregor called it theory x you start by
assuming that people want to do good
work
and so if someone's underperforming you
start by assuming there's something
going on that i don't know
and so that's the beginning you and then
because you're doing it every week it's
like
the person's not going wait that was
three months ago i fixed that now no no
this is last tuesday and wednesday
remember
15 minutes late oh well now the person
may come up with an excuse but the first
thing you do is you ask a question you
shut up you let the person define their
own reality
of course if you're doing that every
week and you're putting together little
strategies to help the person in this
case show up and they don't
then
the
the instinctive insight the best
managers seem to have and the best
coaches
is that your job isn't trying to put in
what god left out
your job is to try to draw out what god
left in your job as a manager is not to
make someone your job as a manager is
not to perfect someone your job is to go
who the heck are you
and then can i find work or indeed a
work context in which you can express
you
and if i've consistently seen
underperformance from you it's not
because you're a bad human it's because
for some reason i put you in the wrong
role in which case my caring doesn't
stop
my loving doesn't stop
i just practice sometimes tough love and
i'll come in and i'll say to you quickly
i love you
uh and you're fired
and i still love you because this job i
i put you in it maybe
and it's wrong for you i can see it you
can see it we can all see it so let's
move you out quickly because this job is
we're not going to rewire your brain
so that you get to be somebody else
you're you and this job doesn't fit you
and it it's my job again another great
question this is a close ended one but
ask great managers would you give people
what they want or do you give them
what's right for them
and you then you just shut up and they
go with the second one you get people
what's right for them even if
occasionally isn't what they want
so
i mean there's more to it than that of
course but but in terms of how best
managers deal with poor performers
frequency ask questions and shut up and
then stop trying to rewire people's
brains
most of high performance is the function
of talent role fit
and when you get low performance is
because the person's not a bad person
it's because they miss fit
and i bet you've seen that with your
people you've had a thousand so you
moved i bet you moved some people
sometimes not always but you go from a c
minus ah so frustrating and then you
tweak the job even just a little and
you're like yeah who are you
and they're extraordinary yeah that's
why i always hate the stuff where people
go well they're an a player it's like
stop categorizing people
a players depend upon which flipping
role you put him in i could take your a
player i'll make him a d
so don't there's no a players there's
just people who really fit their role
and get real joy from it and i'm have
mastery in it etc etc
and then there's people that don't
i bet you've been a b-minus in something
right me too put me in finance i'm at e
yeah right oh he's an a player uh have
you seen his spreadsheets yeah like
so that's that notion of like i'm not
trying to fix you i'm trying to see you
and then find roles in which you can
express you as woo-woo as that sounds
you and i both built businesses we know
it's like no that's not we were at all
that's a good night's sleep that's what
that is when you've got a person and a
team that you go oh
that that's a thing of beauty
one of the things you said as well was
the hardest thing about being a manager
is realizing that your people will not
do things the way that you would
i think everyone can resonate with that
part of the part of the frustration i
think of being a
founder as well is
you
because you're very often very clear on
the way that things you think things
should be done whether that's right or
wrong you just have your own subjective
opinion on how it should be done
or
how hard people should be working
whatever it's sometimes difficult to
appreciate that other people don't have
the same clarity of vision or
perspective as you do i see that
throughout my teams and just with
managers generally they tend to be quite
um what's the word
resentful that their their teams might
not be
doing it the way that they would do it
yes we um some of us get into management
because we want more control yeah and
then you're like uh surprise
you now have to manage by remote control
like you're sitting here people are
doing stuff and you're not there you're
here it's like ah but that's why you
know we talk a lot these days about
feedback and of course the opposite of
feedback on some level is is ignoring
people and people don't want to be
ignored there's no question if you
wanted to destroy your team just ignore
them but
feedback's actually pernicious the best
managers don't give feedback
by which i mean
feedback meaning are you doing this
wrong let me tell you how to do it right
i don't mean feedback as in you got that
fact wrong
um but
in terms of me telling you
this is what your performance is
and this is how you should do it better
that's feedback well you read a lot
right you'll see a lot of tools articles
books even on how you should learn how
to give and receive feedback
uh that's that's
how you grow somebody tells you because
you're blind spots other people they
know the truth about you so they're
gonna tell you who you are because you
can't see it that's called feedback but
of course what that means is that
the person the manager is assuming a
that i do own the truth about you which
they don't we have observer bias like
crazy and i don't mean race gender age
bias i just mean idiosyncrasy in fact in
psychometrics it's called the
idiosyncratic rater effect which means i
have a unique pattern of rating that i'm
unaware of and then when i'm rating you
and i'm rating this person over here and
this person my ratings should move
because i'm looking at different people
they don't my pattern of ratings moves
with me which means that basically all
ratings reflect the rater not the rate
even though we end up paying or firing
or promoting the rate as though the
ratings reflect the rate but they don't
reflect the rater we've known this about
this in in psychometrics for years and
yet in businesses today still most
people
are rated by their manager
but the other thing is in terms of
learning when you give when i give you
feedback and i go do it my way
i mean even with the best of intentions
most feedback basically ends up meaning
you would be better
if only you were more like me yeah
there's a realization at some point
isn't there as an entrepreneur where you
go
i think what i really need to do
is actually just create the conditions
in which a person
can express the best of themselves
rather than me
assuming that learning for that person
is just information transfer and dumping
it into their
blank slate like that's not
at some point as a entrepreneur you
learn what basically brain sciences have
learned for a really long time learning
is insight all learning is insight it
comes from within the person
and so all you can do as a team leader
or manager is create conditions which
within which a person can interact with
the world
a client a prospect a thing they're
making it and then go oh ah ooh ah
and then the person has the learning
you're not telling them how to be when
the moment you tell them how to be is
the moment you're assuming that they are
wired like you are so trying to tell a
person how to sell
it's like
no you sell when the person believes you
and
the prospect believes you and everyone
has a different source of belief
what's yours some people sell through
competence some people sell through
relationships some people sell through
impatience some people sell through
being silent some peop it's like
everybody's source of
belief and trust is totally different
so
yes tell people your reaction as a
manager like if somebody comes in late
you can say look when you come in late
it makes me think you don't care
the person can't then say well you
shouldn't feel that because you go no i
do feel that i feel like you don't care
when or in that meeting when you
interrupted your colleague i felt like
you weren't listening
because i felt that felt weird to me you
shut her down that's what it felt like
to me
that's a reaction
when you then tell the person what to do
differently tell the person how to
change their behavior that's feedback
and you've basically just crossed the
feedback bridge and now you're telling
them how to be
and how to be is how to be more like you
and so
as we talk about in the book a lot it's
like give people your reaction you own
that
don't give people feedback and if you're
on the receiving end of feedback
shut it out because no one knows you
like you know you
it's so true because yeah i mean
everyone says how the importance of
giving feedback and communicating and
the narrative i've always heard in terms
of like management
advice is always you know you've got to
give people constant feedback to help
them
grow
yeah people don't want feedback people
want attention that's different
if you give people no attention they'll
shut down i mean loneliness is a killer
we knew so that's true but people don't
want feedback and imagine when somebody
says to you hey sit down
you want to have a conversation i want
to give you some
feedback
it's like an anvil on your head your
brain leaves the room and all you're
thinking about is how do i survive this
darn thing with marcus because it's
going to turn out to be marcus didn't
tell me something that he's got the
truth about me that i don't have and
then he's going to tell me a bunch of
things and i'm going to have to do this
as he tells me a bunch of tactics and
stuff that don't feel like me
and
and you're just trying to think how do i
survive this conversation here let me
give you some feedback it's like
ah so yeah i'm on a bit of a campaign
going that is so arrogant feedback is
arrogance what people want is attention
which could be your reaction so if you
said to me marcus you know halfway
through that whole session that we did i
thought you got a bit off track
i can't then go no you didn't think that
because you went no i was lost man well
you shouldn't have been lost because i
was being really clear and you go you
but i was lost well that's a reaction
and people do want a reaction there's no
question that's why once a week the
managers really that's what that is is
that once a week check-in is like just
frequent attention they don't want
feedback because they're not you
and they don't want to be you
and i know for me as an entrepreneur
that was the hardest thing to learn was
like
step back
they'll show you who you are who they
are and then you can
help kind of arrange a world in which
they
get to express and express and express
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast
it's so crazy that in the last couple of
months i've had so many people tag me on
instagram even on telegram and in my
twitter dms
in a picture of them starting their heel
journey and it's one of the most
amazing things in my life that i get to
do a podcast which of course needs money
to to fuel and i have a sponsor like you
who i genuinely believe is going to help
every single person
who starts their heel journey change
their life because this podcast the
central intention of this podcast is to
help people live better lives and we get
to sit here and i get to promote to you
a product which has not only helped me
change my life but it's going to help
millions of people and is helping
millions of people live a nutritionally
complete life it's so it's such an
incredible product and for me the reason
why it's incredible is because it gives
me my protein it gives me my vitamins
minerals it's plant-based it's low in
sugar gluten-free it does all of that in
a small drink that tastes good there are
other products there's foods there's the
hot and savory collection many other
things but for me
this ready to drink is the absolute
saviour of my diet throughout the week
where i'm moving at such pace
look i don't want to labor the point but
if you haven't tried you'll give it a
try and if you do
tag me instagram wherever you try it
give me a tag anyway
back to the podcast
why did you call the book love
and work why the word love in particular
well i i did it as a
two reasons one the juxtaposition is
always interesting
like one piece like love and work you
just don't hear them
said that way
um so on part of it was like
it just gets your attention
and the other part of it from a research
standpoint if you interview people that
are really really good at what they do
and that's really been my entire career
and i was talking to you before about
study group contrast for 25 years that's
all i've been doing you take
100 great nurses 100 great teachers 100
great housekeepers 100 great lawyers
and you're just asking open and get
ended questions you're shutting up
you're tape recording the whole thing
transcribing it and going hmm what's
there and when you do that
the best people in any job they don't
all love the same things but there's
love in what they do
there's um
vanishing into the activity the activity
isn't something they're doing it's
something they're being
whether it's cleaning a room and
vacuuming themselves out so they can see
the lines and they get kicked out of the
lines whether it's another housekeeper
going i lie on the bed and turn on the
ceiling fan
and i remember back then going why
because that's the first thing a guest
does after a long day at the theme parks
and i like looking at the room through
the lens of the guest you're like
whoa but i love looking at the room
that's why i sit on the toilet or i lie
in the bath even though there's rules in
the job description say do not lie you
know in the bath or sit on the toilet
you're like whoa
so when you look at really really good
people in any job they find love in the
activities themselves
interestingly though they don't love all
they do the whole cliche about find what
you love and you'll never have to do a
day's work in your life again
and i'm a bit of a data nerd so you look
around and you go is that true
and you study the most successful people
my first um master's thesis actually at
school was the social and psychological
issues of entrepreneurship
even the best entrepreneurs don't love
all they do and so you go okay find what
you love to do and you never have to
work around your life again is there any
data to support that at all no none so
let's stop saying that
and let's rehabilitate with science the
word love
measurably when you study highly
successful people they find love in what
they do they don't love all that they do
but they find love in what they do they
find activities or moments or situations
every day
that they love
how many 100 50
20 is a really good threshold mayo
clinic research shows doctors and nurses
who are not burned out have at least 20
of their activities be things that they
love take a bunch of emergency room
nurses they love different things but 20
you get below 20
19 18 17 it's like you start getting
really dangerously psychologically
damaged
even if it's you know
21 though 27 50
it doesn't seem as though you get
necessarily a massive uplift in
resilience it's not like you need to
love all you do
20 is a threshold like get above that
and every day feels different
every day feels different so
and then of course if we dive into the
brain science of it you find that when
people are actually in that state of
the positive psychologist who we lost
last year mike czech shema high he
called it flow
okay when you get into that flow state
even if it's just 20 of your time if you
look at someone's brain when they're in
the moment in the zone in their element
whatever your phrases they have the same
chemical cocktail in their brain as you
do when you're in love with someone
so vasopressin oxytocin norepinephrine
with the addition of this weird
cocktail called anandamide which is
brings feelings of wonder and ore
but your brain on love
looks at work looks a lot like your
brain on love with another person
and when you're
doing something that you love
you are more open measurably you perform
cognitive tasks better your memories
better you're more accurate in measuring
or identifying the emotions of other
you're just better
so love and work was like hey
if you want this is kind of when i was
sitting there trying to fill the pages
and thinking why are you writing this
on one level i mean one of those
thinking my kids i want my kids to be
happy in life and have joy in what they
do and most people don't and i wanted to
have something i could go read this yeah
you know um but on another level i
wanted to write to ceos like you and me
and go
listen
if you want collaboration if you want
innovation
if you want creativity if you want
really authentic customer focus you
can't get it without love
so if you feel a bash talking about love
then shut up talking about these other
things you won't get them
loveless excellence is oxymoronic
and that's not just a phrase it's like
you look at what people look like on
love at work
and they're amazing
so if we took it seriously
at work
and we thought about what do you love
how does that turn into work and how
does the work that you do inform the
detail of what you love and then it
becomes this wonderful infinite loop
of work is to help you sorry love is to
help you figure out contribution
which then informs what you love like
your life is like this you've already
built a company you've sold it now
you're doing all this other stuff
because your love leads you to turn it
into contribution which required you
spending tens of thousands of pounds to
do something and then now you're doing
it and we're sitting here and there's
there'll be stimuli that information is
going into your brain right now and it
will add detail to that which you love
this whole thing but over here in l.a it
will have a little more detail and your
life will be this now listen i don't
know your mom and your dad but if your
life was like this they would go
yes i don't care how much freaking money
he makes if he knows that which he loves
and turns into contribution then on his
deathbed he'll feel like he lives a
first day version of his life
and i've got an 18 year old and a 20
year old
and i just wish in every fiber of my
being that they get to feel that loop
that's love and work love is for work
and work is for love and if we do that
it's not just individualistically
satisfying it's what companies want from
us we just haven't taken it
we just haven't taken it seriously
um you talked about which i think i
don't know if this was before we start
recording but this the the curse of you
know i remember a conversation i had
with a with a young lady who was a
lawyer
and um she was clearly dissatisfied in
her job
and it transpired that the reason she
was a lawyer is because that's what she
had been good at in terms of a levels
then um university and also her mum and
dad had said like that's a good job and
she she was almost on the verge of a
midlife crisis when she spoke to me
because she had she was so good at this
thing that it kind of dragged her off
into the future and she she was now that
that was her identity so many people
listening to this now will resonate with
that in various ways they would have
become
a banker because their parents were
bankers and they were really good at
maths
what have you found out about those
people their satisfaction
and really what they should be doing i
guess is there something else they
should be doing instead is
should we be dragged by our our
competence in something
well no as we talked about before i mean
competence can be a
a devilish curse um because you can get
the a's and they hate the work you can
get high performance but actually hate
the activities
um
for anyone if they want a a really great
career
the why is important like to think about
do you really believe in the purpose of
what you're doing that's important no
question the who is important no
question
if you hate the people you're working
with that's always a bit of a problem
but the what trumps the who and the i in
the end like what are you actually
filling your days with so if your friend
is a lawyer it's like which
give me a day talk to me about a day
what's the day look like what are you
doing at 10 o'clock on a monday morning
what are you doing at 3 p.m on a
thursday afternoon
that's the what what are the actual
activities themselves so if anyone's the
other
what always trumps the who and the why
which is why we've got nurses and
teachers who are so disengaged they
believe in the why
they really love the people on their
shift but the day-to-day reality of what
they're doing doesn't fit them no one's
paying attention to it there's no
manager helping them there's no teams
all the stuff we talked about before
that that goes
is anyone paying attention to what i
have to do every day and whether or not
it fits me which bits do which bits
don't how do i lean into one another
what is collaborate all that stuff
is missing so the why is there the who
is there the what is wrong so if i say
lawyer that could be a com that's it
could be an entirely different
experience for
you know everybody that's a lawyer so
one lawyer could be doing a completely
different thing different working hours
work from home work in a great team with
you know weekly check-ins yeah and
another lawyer although it's the same
job title could be in an awful corporate
office two-hour commute every day on
their own in a tiny cubicle yes so to
anyone watching or listening
the first thing to do is assess like
where are you at which really means
how much love do you have in a week do
you have a lot do you have a loveless
job
how would you do that well the simplest
way to do it is
just take a blank pad around with you
for a week draw a line down the middle
of it
put love to it at the top of one column
and load it on top of the other and this
is easy to do most people have never
done this
and all you're going to do is you're
going to imagine that your day
is made up of many many different
threads
there's a fabric of a workday it which
bit like a tapestry on a wall when
you're far away it looks like just a
picture but when you get close there's
many many many thousands of threads well
the same is true of any day
you've got a thousand different
activities moments situations context
like just stuff just hits you like and
it's little baby five minutes two
minutes seven minutes five minutes two
minutes seven minutes but these are
threads some of them are white some are
black some of them are gray some are
green they lift you up a little they're
down a little but some of them are red
so in the book here i talk about red
threads activities that when you're
doing them all that stuff we talked
about before the flow the energy the
instinctive volunteering the i'm in my
essence the the feeling of innate
mastery the those moments there could be
like two minutes here seven minutes here
ten minutes but there are red threads
and your life is sort of putting on a
show for you every day going what about
this thread what about that thread what
about this thread what about that thread
and the most successful people in any
job of course they identified their red
threads really well
and then they weave them into
contribution now we can talk more about
how they do that but it starts by going
take a black pad around with you
think about the clues to your red
threads what are you interesting to be
volunteer for while you're doing
something does time fly by when you're
done with it you feel sort of in a sense
of of mastery a sense of being up not
down
and then take it around with you for a
week and anytime you find anything
that fits those criteria scribble it
down
and any time you find the inverse before
you're doing something you try to
procrastinate or or hand it off to the
new guy because it'll be developmental
you know
or or you're doing it and the time drags
on like a snail and it's like you
thought we'd be doing it for an hour but
you look up it's five minutes and we've
all got stuff like that it's like ah and
time and love have a weird relationship
you know it's like when you're with
someone that you love that whole day
goes by in 15 minutes
and yet before you're with them like you
time just stretches out and you're with
them and whoa
um same shoe with an activity that you
love if you you don't love it you keep
trying to do this and then when you're
doing it it's like how's that how was it
this long
um scribble it down and they loathed it
and so get to the end of one week just
one regular week
and see what's in the loved it column
and what's in the lowest column
if there's nothing in the loved it
column well then you have to stop and do
it again next week and pay attention and
if you get no red threads
two weeks in a row and this is really
easy to do no one's ever told people how
to do it but it's really easy to do
you're two weeks in a row of no red
threads
then you've got a loveless job and and
the bad trade for anybody is somebody
going well
my job doesn't have to love me back i'm
making the money
uh i'll just stick it out i'll pay my
dues or i'll earn the money for three
four five years
then i'll
you know that well five years then i'll
as though you emerge the same person
after five years of loveless work you
don't you are psychologically damn it
you're a different person after five
years of loveless work you're damaged
and the people weirdly who feel it the
most are the people you're supposedly
supporting at home you think the people
around the dinner table don't know that
you come back every day on your loved it
loathed it list although they wouldn't
say it this way there's nothing on the
loved it column
they know they can feel it people often
worry about don't bring your personal
stuff to work uh it's way more powerful
the other way people bring their work
their emptiness their alienation at work
back home
so if you two weeks in a row
nothing then you have to stop and you
have to in a sense apply the loved it
loathed it to the rest of your life just
take that around and see whether you can
find any red threads anywhere in your
hobbies as a mother as a father as a
friend in your community in your faith
what i don't know
where
write
one love note to yourself
which is simply i love it when
and then finish the sentence and the
thing after the word when has to be a
verb
that you're doing i love it when people
praise me or something i love it when i
what just write one sentence it's
amazing steve how many people
adults
can't be articulate
about describing something that they
love i know it sounds really weird but
you ask people
we've done this so many times you ask
people you know tell me what you love or
tell me your strengths are oh i love
people
which people
what are you doing with the people give
me a verb any verb will do let's start
with a verb but we've trained people so
long to be
divorced from their own
emotion or believing that basically
their emotion can be rewired if they
just work at it and show enough grit or
whatever and you're like no no no no
it's real you and your emotional
reaction to things is real
so i would say to people first of all do
that love it load it
and then try to write one maybe even two
love it's a silly word but a love note
to yourself i love it when i do what i
love it when i do what
what many people will actually find
is that if you hate lawyering it might
well be that you're the wrong kind of
lawyer it might not be that you have to
ditch your degree
it might be that you can start to
re-wire or re-um
sew
re-weave your job
so that it has more red threads in it
so if you do that for a week and you
find there are a couple of things on
there actually there are a couple of
love bits there are a couple of specific
things where i'm like oh ooh
well when you have that first of all pay
attention to it
things that are not paid attention to
they wither so every day wake up it's
the advice i would give you or you might
give me every day wake up and just try
to rather than what i have to get
through what's the to-do list i have to
get through why don't you wake up every
day
yeah you may have a to-do list but wake
up every day and go what red threads can
i weave today because they're going to
be not 75 000 but there might be five
what are the five start there
and then over time what you'll find is
you can start to maybe go well next week
actually i'm going to pick one day it's
going to be all red it's going to be all
red one day then you might go because
people start to lean into it they might
go could you actually do more of that
for this client and this client in this
client and your and then maybe you learn
a competency like somebody who's
really good at
creating emails that people open you
might go eloqua we'll teach you eloqua
we'll teach you that competency because
you've got something that you seem to be
able to write text that people actually
open that's kind of interesting i know
that's not in your job description but
but you seem to keep doing it and so
we'll teach you now a new competency a
new software program and lo and behold
you start doing that
over time and you get to the place
where the most successful people get to
where we look at the most successful
people and we go
how'd they find that job
seems to fit them so perfectly had they
find that job and of course they know
they didn't find it that's totally the
wrong verb they made it
they took their red to use that metaphor
that they took their red threads
seriously and then they
and they didn't imagine someone could
read their mind and tell them what their
red threads are because only you know
what these things little moments
situations contexts are that really lift
you up but then they took them seriously
and and wove them ever more deeply into
the fabric of what they do now sometimes
that might mean stop being a lawyer
you know what you've worked you've tried
this now for six months and there's
nothing there for you okay well then
that's really tricky
now you have to change
your entire focus and hopefully your
loves will be your guide
but we actually know over here i don't
know the number for the uk but 73 of
americans say that they have the freedom
to maneuver their job to fit themselves
better
that's a lot of people
and yet only 18 of us do because if you
ask people you have a chance to use your
strengths every day that number's 18
so you've got 73
18
in psychology we call that an attitude
behavior consistency problem
i know i can do it
i don't
so that's if people are watching i'm in
the wrong job maybe maybe you're one of
the 27 percent you're in the wrong job
all right before you get there though
try to i pick out your red threads
anywhere
and no one can do it for you that's the
thing that it's like you want to go hey
nine-year-old let's start you on this
life skill early because even at nine
you know better than all your teachers
do
about this part anyway about the red
threads part
and that way when you wake up you know
your mom's going to be a dentist be a
dentist be a dentist and you're like
mom there's a whole language actually
here that talks about dentistry and
whether i love it or not and i'll keep
walking on down that path but i'm
actually supposed to look really
carefully about which bits of any job
really lift me up and give me a sense of
mastery
kids have more of a language as i say in
the book they have more of a language
about geometry than they do about this
thing i was just talking about
so your parents are so powerful and
they're so scared
and they want you to not be a layaband
they want you to be able to get a job
and they want they're so scared for you
but what they've not done and even the
best teachers are so scared for you come
on stephen you can
and no one really goes
wait a minute
how do you make sense of your own
emotion in your own life what do you
lean into what are you not leaning to
what are the words for that is there any
detail around that or what do you like
about people what do you like doing with
the people you imagine how early you
could start with that
and that wouldn't mean that it's
pollyanna like we're still going to put
people in the wrong jobs i built a
company that was focused entirely on
people's strengths and i still put
people on the wrong job
because people are
super complicated
but at least we'd have a framework
and a set of shared understandings about
what we were even trying to do
i don't know i think there's for all of
us there's stuff we can do you don't
have to change the company you'd have to
change all the hr policies you could any
one of us could start right now
to do what the most successful people do
in terms of weaving red threads into
their into their work
what were the in chapter 2 i know you
talked about having panic attacks when
you're i believe at gallup what were the
red threads that were missing in your
role then that led you to getting to a
point where you were having panic
attacks and how did you sort of rectify
that personally
yeah that's you know it's funny this
i've written
a lot of books a lot of them have mostly
been about data
and uh
that's fine because i like
i like the precision of data
but i felt like like many people i'm
sure the pandemic the last few years
have been really difficult for us and
you sort of ask yourself what
what are you doing with your life what
life you living or what
mark you're leaving you know i lost my
dad i lost my marriage i saw my company
pandemic
you sort of look in the mirror and
you're like what am i doing
so for this book i was like you know i'm
a repressed brit
um but i'll put my own story in here
because i feel like
it's more honest and everybody's life is
a story the only one i can tell is mine
maybe i could share parts of it and
other people could learn
to tell their own story so i did put
things in there that i have buried
buried buried
and
yeah 29 i was managing gallup's
relationship with the walt disney
company
so i was living down in orlando and um
i
did start having really bad i didn't
know what a panic attack was i mean as i
said in the book now everyone knows all
about panic attacks and it's like it's
like acne right everyone has them and
it's great
or not great but um i didn't know i
thought i was going mad i mean i thought
it's the pre the
it's the build-up as the doctor told me
it was like it's not that one moment
that's causing the panic attack it's the
build up actually of
again we talk about love as a force like
if you don't express that which you love
it's not neutral
it turns from a beautiful powerful
force love into a really caustic
substance that eats away at you it's
damaging
so for me i had got myself into a
position where
i was
i was really
solely responsible for one
huge client
disney
and i was the interface
between gallup
with all the people on the teams
and disney
and i hate that
i hate having to be responsible for
other people's emotions
that i can't do anything about
i hated that every single day waking up
and thinking
are the 200 people that are basically
our clients at disney are they happy
what are they thinking what are they
wondering about what do they need do
they need this did they
i
i mean even just saying that now makes
me break out in a sweat because it's
like i can't do that i don't
i'm not a connector like that i'm not a
connector
i don't like reaching in going oh if i
say this to this person and this to this
person then megan is and yet that's
really what the job had become and
i like i mean when i think about what i
love
i love when i have a chance to sit down
and really grind on an idea or a set of
data to come up with a conclusion that's
based on data like i love that i love
trying to get up on stage and try to
figure out the most evocative way to
help someone realize a particular
insight that i've come up with like
that's a love note for me
and more and more and more i was doing
less and less and less of that
and instead i was holding the emotions
of the people behind me at gallup and
the people in front of me at the walt
disney company
and
for me
for no good reason
it panics
me
now i should have known better i guess
um
i hadn't done the love it loaded thing
back then hadn't even thought about it
all the way through to the word love
but
it was clearly a loveless existence
and when anyone has loveless work that
they're pat you know they believe in it
but the days are empty psychologically
empty you don't get to express that
which it's like being a loveless
relationship it's like it's awful
even if you feel like you want to help
that other person
if the being of relationship with them
doesn't allow you to express who you are
they don't see who you are they see who
you are and wish you weren't that way
it's awful
so for me that's i think what built up
and up and up and up and up and in the
end it was like it was super
psychologically
damaging
to be trying to be somebody that you're
not
when you
you didn't plan to be there but now
everyone's counting on you
to be a certain way and i don't mean in
a macro sense to be a certain way i mean
at two o'clock on a thursday afternoon
you're supposed to be thinking and
feeling this and it might you know nine
o'clock on a monday you're supposed to
be feeling all
and you realize your days are filled
with empty minutes
week after week
meditation
yeah that became a
tool for you right yes i'm a huge
advocate of
what you can see from love and work is
like the first relationship you better
have is a really good one with yourself
and so the point of love and work on one
level was to help everybody have a more
articulate fluency with their own
language
with their own reaction to the world and
so that begins on some level by shutting
out
i mean here am i chatting away like a
mad prune but
um
can you breathe in and breathe out for
15 minutes
i mean that's i don't know do you do you
meditate i try sometimes when i'm with
my partner i do we do breath work and
stuff like that which is a kind of a
meditative practice um
i do like micro meditations which is
during the day if i notice that my
breath is incredibly shallow i'll go
i'll try and do the seven second thing
yeah and i try and take time to just do
that but i'm i've never been
too good at the whole like 15 20 minutes
alone thing
it's
well again everyone's different right so
who would dream of saying to you you
should meditate all i know is when i had
a chance to try to
be in sync with my own breath
it gave me power
i felt
and so when
the disney people were freaking out or
behind me the gala people were freaking
out i was like
i was okay with it but as i said in the
book that was a coping mechanism it
wasn't a flourishing mechanism i'm not
saying some people can't flourish
through meditation they probably can't i
couldn't for me it was like i got clear
enough in my own head to realize
this isn't what i should be doing
this is a big
miss match between me
and what somehow
i was getting paid to do
prestige is a big thing right it's like
somebody goes you want to run the disney
account
how much money will i make what's my
title oh wow oh wow yeah i'll do that
and so you end up
in a role where you it's a i call it the
book of mystery
i thought they're gonna say miss
instinct oh yeah
a miss instinct like you go y'all do
that you raise your hand but you're like
yeah
everyone has that and i when i read that
i think chapter 11 everyone has that in
their lives where you you're offered a
promotion for example and because i mean
who turns down a promotion i had this
really interesting day in my company
many years ago where i called in the
head of mark the
header he was the marketing manager and
i said you've been here four years now
um we're gonna give you a promotion
you're gonna become the head of
marketing for the uk and the us
and he was like
no
i was like what he was like no no i'm
not i don't i don't want that i'm not
right he was i'm not ready for it yet
and he'd been there four years
and i don't want it and i walked out of
that room and i tell you the amount of
respect i had for that individual for
being able to say no to a promotion
because they were didn't like weren't
ready for that yet i just thought
unbelievable this is someone that's
actually going to be happy in their life
well and the funny thing is at work
right we because we don't start really
early and say to people hey listen
you're a totally unique human being and
the way in which you respond to the
activities of school is really
interesting and let's help you have a
language for that then you get to go
into a job and you don't really have a
language for that and then somebody
comes in and says i'm gonna give you a
promotion
and you on some inco at level you're
like oh wait a minute i really really
love this like i'm i'm so into the
design that i'm doing i love the fact
that it's me doing the doing and i'm not
responsible for someone else who's doing
the doing i'm the one making the
decisions i love the thing that i made
yesterday and the other thing i'm gonna
make tomorrow and you and it takes such
strength of character to go when
somebody comes in and says no we're
gonna promote you out of it it's like
how weird is it at work that the most
creative way we've thought to reward
someone for being really good at a job
is to move them out of it like that's
bizarre they call it the peter principle
right that you keep playing with that
you just get promoted to your level of
of incompetence that's that's the peter
prince lawrence piece i think was the
professor who came up with that
it takes such strength of character for
that person to go
wait a minute you're saying i would get
to do less of all this stuff that really
really invigorates me yes that's what
i'm saying
why would i want that well it's going to
come with a bigger title and more money
yeah but yeah but
it doesn't i loved it now that's
self-awareness
that's self-mastery
obviously in the in the last or second
the last chapter of the book came to our
love and work organization we ought to
create broader pay bans that allow
someone to grow in their role extend
their contribution and yet not
necessarily have to move out of the job
in order to manage other people that
doesn't have to be
the only way in which we help someone
have a career that was a really as you
said i was just it just reminded me that
one of the most
um
interesting points of feedback that i
got
in terms of
pushback when someone was getting a
promotion was their realization that
that would change the team dynamics for
them so if they were becoming a manager
i often heard people say things like
they didn't want to become a manager or
not even just in my companies but just
generally people message me on instagram
or linkedin they're hesitant to become a
manager because they feel like the
friendships that they have in their team
would then change they then have to
speak to the people in a certain way and
have to have this like there becomes
this hierarchy which they don't actually
want it's really interesting
one of the great questions to ask people
to see if they want to move into
management is simply the question would
you rather do a job yourself or would
you rather be responsible for other
people's work
that's a great i know it's not an
open-ended question but it actually
turns out to be for some crazy reason a
beaut people don't lie to that question
i don't know why we've asked it probably
50 000 times and it's as a predictor of
whether somebody actually then excels as
a manager there's an awful lot of people
who deep down you throw them that
question and top of mind they go
i'd rather be responsible for my own
work actually
and there's a manager or sorry as an
entrepreneur often we go well
you'll grow into this you will and on
some deep level there's you could you
could probably split the world into two
there are some people even though they
have friendships
they go i think i know how to do this
though i like being responsible for
other people's
work their choices i like being the one
to hold them i like
even though i'm a friend and i love them
i like being the one to try to help them
as we talk about them about what's the
point of a relationship
and that's by the way a super i think a
super interesting question what's the
point of a relationship
is it diversity is it protection is it
complementarity
actually no it's just any relationship
even a lover relationship is
i want to make you bigger
i want to make you bigger
i see you
i don't want to try to correct you
perfect you i just want to make you
bigger like what a beautiful
relationship that is to be in where you
know the person sees you
like shuts up and listens or watches
and then you know that their intention
toward you is
not competing with you they just want
you to do this
and it's like wow and for many really
great managers
they've got friendships like you
shouldn't be a friend of people you
manage that's just absolutely no data on
that at all
some managers are best friends with the
people they manage but they have a
relationship where that person feels
like that manager
who's really just another human wants
you to be bigger
and that's
that's as cool as heck that is if you've
got a work team
where people on the team feel like my
manager who might well be my friend
wants me
to expand not to become someone else
like it's not like i don't see you and
here's my model of who you should be and
you better fit it it's more like no who
are you oh that's this is how that might
look for you as you grow
some people
i don't know if i'm one of them
but some people are able to maintain
those beautiful friendships and still
move into managing because they see
managing in a sense as an extension of
what a beautiful relationship is anyway
i know they always say don't get too
close to your people because you might
have to fly them
and then you ask really great managers
can you ever care too much for your
people every one of them goes no the
best ones you can never care too much
now look
capitalism capitalism sometimes you run
out of business and our clients ditch us
and we've got to downscale the company
yeah and that's that doesn't mean i
don't care it means this is a bloody
problem sometimes you get you in the
wrong role as i said earlier tough love
but there's love there's big love there
and
you know people always say well too much
love in the workplace is soft it's like
think about people you really love
if they were abusing drugs
you would intervene
you would because you would not your
love would be like i can't let you keep
doing this not because i don't love you
but because i do
well at work
sometimes we're going to go this job is
i don't know man i love the the salary
is good for you i get it this job is not
right for you
and i'm saying that to you because it's
hard for me to say to you it's difficult
and you don't want me to say to you
but i love you and this is wrong for you
and if we got more of that at work
that's not idealistic the best managers
in any company
do that and that's why when they leave a
company all their people run with them
because it's so
delightful and human
and possible
um
yeah what did you learn then about you
referenced romantic relationships there
and much of your work centers on you
know the relationship of one person to
another and how to optimize and get the
best out of it what advice would you
give me on how to have a successful
romantic relationship in terms of
principles based on all you've learned
from your book love and work but also
all of your previous work on
relationships and
yeah so
it's funny to write there's a whole
chapter here on love and work
relationships particularly after the
metoo movement you think well you
shouldn't bring up love and work like
that's just that's
leads to bad situations and
um but the person who i'm i'm getting
married like the person i'm used to work
for me so and depending on which data
you look at between 22 and 27 percent of
people met their partner at work their
life partner at work
so clearly seeing somebody at work is
kind of cool because you see all the
bits of them and you see them doing kind
of wonderful and crazy things doesn't
mean that we shouldn't have ways sort of
ways in which people have relationships
at work but
um but it's obviously the you can't
really write a book about love and work
and not talk about love so
and i'm going to sound so bloody
nerdy saying this
but there's actually quite a lot of
research on what it means to see someone
with love like there's a
what does it look like when you're in a
love relationship that works mostly of
course when we study relationships we
study broken ones so we study divorce to
learn about marriage as though
you know happiness is the opposite of
sadness it's like
no
but there has been some research
studying happy marriages and when you
look at what characterizes a really
successful relationship three things
stand out and they're all weird
the first one is
um they had couples rate each other on a
list of qualities and you would think
that in the best relationships if i
rated myself high on
uh impatience and low on creativity and
then high on urgency and low and then my
partner
rated me the same my our patterns
matched then you think well that's a
good relationship because then they your
partner sees you the way that you see
you and love shouldn't be blind love's
not blind love's like clear-eyed i mean
love starts blind they're amazing but
then you see them and who they really
are and then boom boom boom but actually
in the best relationships the ones that
tracked over time
um less conflicts uh more longing more
yearning for each other over time in the
best relationships the other partner
rates you high on everything
the other partner sees you with rose
tinted glasses the whole time and they
do that because you then why does that
serve the relationship well you feel
uh you feel so safe and they feel so
confident because they see you like this
so that's the first thing keep your rose
tinted glasses on in a relationship the
second thing i would say to you is
if you want to be a good partner to your
partner or if you want them to be a good
partner to you
always
look for the best explanation of why
they do what they do and believe it
there's an awful lot of reasons why you
do what you do some of them are not
noble some of them might be selfish 100
and if you're with a partner who
you know they keep coming in and going
what's the real reason you do you know
do you know why you did that because you
bla if you're living with a detective
oh god forbid you're living with a
therapist who's like let me tell you why
you really said that it goes all the way
back to your mom is what it does you
know that's
then you here's what you do you bury it
you you armor yourself against the
detective because the detective is
sometimes right
if you want to think about what serves a
relationship it's to be in a
relationship with someone who's always
looking for the most generous
explanation for why you do what they do
and then they believe it because if they
believe it then they actually lean in
more and you are more vulnerable because
you go deep down you go there's all
sorts of reasons why i did that but they
are looking for the most generous one
that doesn't mean they let you off the
hook if you let them down i'm not saying
that but as you look at what the best
couples do they look for the of all the
reasons why you do something and it's
never one reason there's a lot of
different ones they look for the most
generous one and then they believe it
and then the third thing in in really
great relationships is that you never in
a relationship
balance out
um
well he's impatient
but at least he's creative
i mean he is so disorganized
but at least he's charming
like
if if you have that kind of detail about
your weaknesses and you know your
partner knows these really really well
even though they love you for this they
go no but he's just awful at this this
is like a villain that sits off in the
wings and you know when you're arguing
your partner whenever they want they can
just pull out the card and play the
villain card and go see this is you and
you know this person knows you better
than anyone else in the world has 17 000
examples of why that villain is real and
lives in you that means you do this you
just keep leaning back and back and
every argument you're like when are they
going to play the card when are they
going to play the card hurts the
relationship in the best relationships
turns out
ev your partner looks at you
everything they see about you
they weave it into
i'm sorry this is going to sound so soft
but they weave it into a red thread
so they know that this isn't an aspect
of something over here that's separate
it's part of what you contribute to the
world and the example i gave in here my
shell my fiance is
oh gosh we are not an example but i mean
we're an example just of ourselves so we
you know we argue and we're up and down
so but one of the beautiful things about
my relationship with her is
is
i i have immediate rejection syndrome
where because i like to really noodle on
an idea when people come to me with
ideas sometimes if my mental brain is
full i go no like it's an immediate
rejection syndrome which she called
immediate rejection syndrome as a joke
and rather than saying putting it over
here it's a villain she's
in our relationship it works such that
she knows that this is a part
of me wanting to get to the core of an
idea so that i can actually push it all
the way through to what i consider to be
something really deep or wise or true
and and like if i
can't get there yet because i'm still
grinding on it then it turns out to be
immediate rejection syndrome but but if
you try to un
weave that you would unravel all of this
which is the only good i'm ever going to
do in the world is this so i'm with a
partner who's like i get and by the way
sometimes marcus is bloody annoying but
i get that it's a part of this
it doesn't excuse it like should i not
be blunt when i go no
um yeah but i know that she knows that i
know that she knows that i know that she
knows that i know that this is a part of
me doing anything good she's not
putting the villain over here he rejects
ideas
it's like oh no he needs to grind on him
and sometimes that manifests in this and
that's the acceptance piece which i
think everybody and being seen and being
seen so it's like you can't love what
you can't see
and so in a relationship if you're in a
really good relationship with your
partner
you will feel seen
and then intelligently
you will see that person go oh that's
why he does what he does and then you
know that they're looking at you with
those beautiful rose tinted glasses on
not to pat you on the head
but to have really beautiful and
powerful expectations of you based upon
what they see
now that's a relationship
and that doesn't mean you don't argue
but it means you're in the hands of
somebody who wants you who wants you to
be this
like that's intoxicating and super sexy
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast oh the previous guest writes a
question for the next guest and they
don't know who they're writing it for
and we'll ask you to do the same as well
um the previous guest who sat here
yesterday wrote a question for you not
knowing who you were
and they said
okay
tell me something about yourself
that no one knows
and would be surprised to know about you
oh i like that one
that is a stitch up
[Laughter]
well the challenge there is i wrote
about some things that i've never
written about in love and work
that i've never shared so
i now have shared that i couldn't say my
own name until i was 12.
which i don't think anyone would really
have known given what i do
um
i look like i sort of feel confident but
i had
years of panic attacks so
those are now
shared and for me we're like really
um
really hard
um
and i think the other thing when i wrote
about
my children and i we didn't get into it
but the whole like college cheating
scandal thing for me was
really difficult to see my the world
reach into your kids so the panic that
you feel when you realize the world i
mean you're a social media expert right
you know how porous
the world is um and
so inside of this person is a
is a person who
is
now forever fearful of how the world can
reach into your life
and
completely mess it up
and
the struggle that i probably have that
doesn't people don't know is how do you
ensure that you aren't cynical
how do you ensure that you retain
some of the joy and the ore like we
didn't meet before like i've loved this
and i've probably talk too much but
yeah
it's an awe-inspiring thing to me
another human and i want to be able to
retain all of that openness in this in
the face of a world that's sometimes
really
uh dangerous it's a challenge right yeah
yeah
cynicism's the death of love
thank you so much marcus honestly um
it's really astounding that there was a
point in this human being's life where
you couldn't speak because you were one
of the most eloquent powerful engaging
speakers i think i've ever had on this
podcast and um you know you talk about
it in the book when when time flies you
know you've been enjoying it and time is
certainly fun we've been here for more
than two hours now so yeah
and it feels like 10 minutes and i mean
i don't need to to evangelize about the
quality of the book you've written
because i think everyone that's just
listened to this conversation can
understand the wisdom and the value of
this book just by listening to our
conversation but i will anyway it really
is a brilliant book and there's certain
books that i come across sometimes that
are written in such a way that time does
fly as you're reading them and you come
away with a real profile almost like
you'd been through a um
almost a cathartic therapeutic journey
and i ha from this conversation but also
from this book i have a very long list
of things that i immediately think i
need to do differently in my life that i
think will lead to better outcomes um
and the way that you deliver the message
on this podcast but also in the book is
in a as a helpful friend that's guiding
me there as opposed to a preacher that
knows best and and that's why this book
is so important so thank you it's my
pleasure it's been a real pleasure and
um we're going to do this again soon
sometime because you really are a
special orator and communicator and well
i really appreciate it i uh
yeah i'm in the war of anybody who's
done what you've done frankly who
started businesses and built businesses
and and gone across town as it were
stopped like to stop late to stop like
making it up and now you're doing this
so it was a real honor to be invited on
i've and yeah time has
time has flown by
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
they make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery this lion piece they've made i
wear all the time along with the little
timepiece the sand timer that i wear
often and the line piece you might have
seen conor mcgregor has a similar piece
which was custom made for him for me it
represents courage and if you walk
through my house the house that i'm in
right now if you walk six feet in that
direction you'll see a huge lion
portrait if you go upstairs you'll see a
lion portrait if you look behind me on
the shelf near the top there you'll see
a line as well the reason my house and
my life is surrounded by lions is
because they represent courage
calmness and that tenacity that i've
applied to my business success to my
professional life into everything in
between for me the lion has always been
an animal that can be almost a bit of a
contradiction they are so loving and so
caring of their own and can be powerful
and courageous when necessary in order
to achieve what they want to achieve so
if you like me are a big fan of courage
bravery ambition while also being
calm and composed check out this line
piece and let me know if you get it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you